>> QUITE CONVENIENTLY FOR MR.
BANKMAN-FRIED'S COUNSEL HE IS
ARRESTED RIGHT BEFORE HE WAS DUE
TO PROVIDE HOURS WORTH OF SWORN
TESTIMONY TO CONGRESS.
>> GETTING SIX HOURS OF
CONGRESSIONAL GRILLING FOR A
TARGETE
TARGETED INVESTIGATION FOR A
DEFENDANT, THAT WOULD BE GREAT
FOR MY CASE.
>> Sandra: ARREST OF FTX FOUNDER
SAM BANKMAN-FRIED RAISING MORE
QUESTIONS AND NOT JUST ABOUT THE
COLLAPSE.
THEY NABBED HIM LESS THAN 24
HOURS BEFORE HE WAS SET TO
TESTIFY ON CAPITOL HILL, ALBEIT
REMOTELY.
SOME ARE QUESTIONING THE TIMING.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR MIRANDA
DEVINE JOINS US NOW.
I TAKE MYSELF BACK TO THE NIGHT
BEFORE WHEN THE ARREST TOOK
PLACE AND WE WERE PLANNING OUR
SHOWS FOR THE NEXT DAY, WE KNEW
WE WERE GOING TO HAVE THIS
HEARING HAPPENING, WE WERE GOING
TO SEE THIS ALLEGED CON MAN
TESTIFY BEFORE THE HOUSE
COMMITTEE AND WHAM-O, THE ARREST
TOOK PLACE AND WHAT WENT THROUGH
YOUR MIND?
>> I JUST IMMEDIATELY SMELLED A
RAT.
THIS IS EXTREMELY SUSPICIOUS
TIMING.
THERE'S NO REASON FOR THEM TO
HAVE NABBED HIM THERE AND THEN,
THEY COULD HAVE WAITED A FEW
HOURS.
THEY SORT OF -- THE IDEA HAD
BEEN FLOATED AROUND THAT HE WAS
A FLIGHT RISK.
I MEAN, HE'S BEEN THERE FOR
WEEKS.
IF HE WAS A FLIGHT RISK, HE
WOULD HAVE LEFT.
HIS MOTHER WAS IN COURT IN THE
BAHAMAS ON TUESDAY MORNING AND
SHE JUST LAUGHED OUT LOUD AT THE
IDEA THAT HE WAS -- HE WOULD BE
A FUGITIVE.
SO THAT DOESN'T PASS THE SNIFF
TEST.
THEY ARE OBVIOUSLY TRYING TO
PROTECT SOMEONE, AND THERE'S A
COUPLE OF THEORIES, ONE IS
BECAUSE SAM BANKMAN-FRIED WAS
THE SECOND LARGEST DONOR AFTER
GEORGE SOROS TO THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, AND THERE'S TALK OF AS
MUCH AS HALF A BILLION DOLLARS
ALREADY GONE TO SORT OF DARK
MONEY PACS FOR THE DEMS, AS WELL
AS HE PROMISED ANOTHER
$1 BILLION FOR THE 2024
ELECTION.
NOW, THEY DON'T WANT THAT MONEY
TO REALLY BE SCRUTINIZED TOO
CLOSELY, PERHAPS THAT'S THE CASE
AND A POLITICAL ISSUE IN
CONGRESS, AND THE OTHER MAYBE
EVEN MORE LIKELY REASON IS THAT
GARY GENZLER, THE HEAD OF THE
SECURITIES AND EXCHANGE
COMMISSION, HAD MET TWICE WITH
SAM BANKMAN-FRIED IN THE PAST
YEAR, PRETTY UNPRECEDENTED, AND
HE ALSO OBVIOUSLY HAD NOT
DONE -- PUT THE CORRECT
REGULATIONS AROUND THAT INDUSTRY
AND AROUND WHAT SBF WAS DOING,
IT'S LIKE HE WAS TURNING A BLIND
EYE.
AND WE ALSO FOUND OUT CURIOUSLY
FROM A FOX NEWS EXCLUSIVE THAT
GARY GENZLER HAD SCRUBBED THE
DETAILS FROM HIS DIARY, HIS
PUBLIC DIARY OF MEETINGS WITH
GEORGE SOROS, HILLARY CLINTON
HIS FORMER BOSS, HE USED TO BE
THE FINANCE CHAIR OF HER
CAMPAIGN, AND ALSO NANCY PELOSI.
SO, WHAT IS GOING ON?
IT'S SOMETHING FISHY, AND IT IS
JUST SHAMEFUL THAT THE DOJ WOULD
BE INVOLVED IN, IF THEY WERE, IN
COVERING UP AND MAKING THIS
TIMING SO CONDUCIVE TO SAM
BANKMAN-FRIED'S DEFENSE
ATTORNEYS, NOT TO THE
PROSECUTORS.
>> Sandra: AND AS FAR AS
PRECEDENT IN THE HOURS THAT
FOLLOWED, WE WERE ABLE TO CATCH
UP WITH JONATHAN TURLEY AND VERY
SIMILARLY HE SAID THIS.
>> THIS IS THE FIRST TIME IN MY
MEMORY THAT PROSECUTORS RATHER
THAN DEFENSE ATTORNEY STOPPED
SOMEONE FROM MAKING
SELF-INCRIMINATING STATEMENTS.
THIS WAS A WINDS FALL
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PROSECUTORS.
HE WAS WILLING TO GO FORWARD
WITH HOURS OF RATHER HOSTILE
CROSS EXAMINATION ON EVERY
DETAIL IN THE CASE.
WHY WOULDN'T YOU WANT THAT TO
HAPPEN?
THAT'S ALL ADMISSIBLE.
>> Sandra: IT SEEMS SO SIMPLE
AND YOU ASKED THE SAME QUESTION
IN THE PIECE, IF YOU ARE A
PROSECUTOR, WOULDN'T YOU BE
DISAPPOINTED NOT TO BRING HIM IN
UNDER OATH, AND FINALLY FOLLOW
THE MONEY, SBF DONATIONS AND THE
PERCENT THAT WENT TO LIBERAL
CAUSES, NUMBER ARE ASTRONOMY L
CA.
AND ALMOST 39 MILLION WENT TO
LIBERAL CAUSES.
AS YOU SAY IN YOUR PIECE,
DEMOCRATS AND PERHAPS
REPUBLICANS WERE SPARED THE
EMBARRASSMENT OF THIS BEING
EXPOSED DURING A HOUSE COMMITTEE
HEARING.
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK IT'S TRUE
AT ALL, THERE'S NO EVIDENCE FOR
WHAT SAM BANKMAN-FRIED SAYS THAT
HE GAVE EQUALLY TO DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICAN, IT'S LAUGHABLE, BUT
GAVE A FEW MILLION TO
REPUBLICANS AND THEY SHOULDN'T
ALLOW THAT TO PREVENT THEM FROM
QUESTIONING WHAT WENT ON WITH
THIS -- THESE SLUSH FUNDS.
IT LOOKED LIKE THAT COMPANY,
FTX, WAS A GIANT MONEY
LAUNDERING OPERATION TO PROVIDE
MONEY FROM BIG CORPORATES TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND THE
REPUBLICANS SHOULD FOLLO